[Evans] Here's one way to define sum_list.
It's a procedure that takes in 1 input,
and we'll name the input p as the name for our parameter.
I tend to use p as the name for a list. There's no really good reason for that.
I don't want to use the letter l because l looks too much like a 1.
I don't want to use m, n, or o because m and n are used usually to represent numbers
and o looks too much like a 0.
So the first good letter to use after l is p.
Of course you could use any name you want for your parameter name.
To define sum_list we're going to introduce a variable to keep track of the sum so far.
Let's call that result.
Initially, the value of the result of 0.
Next we'll use a for-loop to go through the elements.
We're going to go through the elements of p.
Each time we execute the block of the for-loop
the value of e will be the current element of p,
and we'll go through the loop once for each element of p in order.
So what we want to do is add that value to result.
When we then get to the for-loop, that means we've gone through all the elements
and we should return the result.
Let's try this in the Python interpreter.
We've defined sum_list.
Let's try running it.
We do get the value 12.
What do you think would happen if we run sum_list like this,
passing in the empty list?
The answer is that we get the value 0,
which is what we expect, right?
The sum of no elements is 0.
And if we look at the code, that's exactly what happens.
Initially, we set the result to 0.
The for-loop goes through all the elements of p,
but if there are no elements of p, it doesn't execute at all.
And so we go to the next statement, which returns the result, which has the value 0.